GOOD
GOOD MORNING- WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
HEARING I DO THE STAY AT HOME
WATER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEEN HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASS BE WORN IN FISCAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM RIGHT A VIDEO VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. TODAY IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS. FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM. FOR TODAY IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS. WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTENTION OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACING. RUSSELL
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM.
REMEMBER THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK THAT YOU APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING TO
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
TODAY'S AGENDA WILL BE TAKEN
UP. IN THE ORDER LISTED ON THE
AGENDA WHICH SHOULD E EASY
BECAUSE THERE'S ONLY ONE BILL-
IN THE DAILY FILE IN. IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER- SINCE
THERE'S ONLY ONE BILL THAT
WE'LL START WITH PETE TODAY- IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE SOME- BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF OUR
WITNESS. VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS- WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE
IN THE CAPITAL ARE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS. LOCATED ON
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS AT OTHER
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WAS WITH WITH WITNESSES MAY
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM. ALSO ASKING QUESTIONS.
FOR DIALING WITNESSES WE WILL
BE USING. A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS CODE IS
TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. ALL ALSO FIND THIS NOW
ON THE ASSEMBLY. HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IN THE DAILY
FILE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON HIS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE- BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIFE-
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
AGAINST A BILL YOU WILL YOUR
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE AND- WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF INTO YOUR
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
SEVEN AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL WITH
INSTRUCTIONS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. HE COULD FIND EMAIL
FOR THE COMMITTEE THERE AS
WELL. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US- AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF COLOR CALIFORNIA.
ALSO BEING MINDFUL RESPECTFUL
OF THE HEALTH. CONCERNS WE ALL
FACED- MEMBERS- SEE. IF YOU TO
RESPOND ROLL CALL ASK QUESTION
PRIVATE COMMENT. IS RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE SO WITH STAFF CAN
ACTIVATE IT WILL RECOGNIZE YOU
TO SPEAK. ALSO PLEASE STAND UP
FACE A MICROPHONE WHILE
SPEAKING TO ENSURE YOUR VOICE
IS AUDIBLE IN COULD BE
RECORDED. MEMBERS WILL NOT BE
RECOGNIZED- IF THEY ARE NOT-
WHERE TO FACE TODAY THAT THAT
WILL BE A PROBLEM. TIME LIMITS
IN FAIRNESS EVERYONE. WILL NEED
TO BE ESPECIALLY STRICT WITH ON
TIME LIMITS TODAY WE'RE HERE UP
TO TWO WITNESSES FOR THREE
MINUTES EACH. WHAT FOR EACH
SIDE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL
BE LIMITED TO THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF THEY REPRESENT
ONE. AND A POSITION ON THE
BILL- THERE ARE NO CONSENT
BILLS TODAY THERE'S ACTUALLY
JUST ONE- ONE BILL. SO WITH
THAT. LOOKING AROUND. WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM. BUT WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED A SENATOR
PAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
YOUR BILL. THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH- CHAIR WOULD AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE YOU KNOW I THINK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT. SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGE
EIGHT OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO. IS A BILL
THAT REQUIRES THE STATE TO
CONTRACT OUR THE PARTNER. TO
MANUFACTURE AT LEAST TEN
GENERIC DRUGS INCLUDING INSULIN
WHAT THE INTENT THAT THESE
DRUGS BE MADE WIDELY AVAILABLE.
NOW THE ADMINISTRATION AND THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS WORKED HARD
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
PHARMACEUTICAL. COSTS IS IN THE
SENATE CENTER HERNANDEZ HAD
AUTHORED A BILL THAT'S NOW LAW
TO TRACK THE PRICING AND THEN I
KNOW TAT- SUMMER WOULD IN THIS
COMMITTEE HAS ALSO PUT FORTH A
LEGISLATION AS WELL AS LAST
YEAR WE WORKED ON AND AG BILL
YOU. AUTHORED AG BILLS I SURE
WOULD- TO ADDRESS- ACTUALLY
GENERICS AND THAT THE COSTA
GENERICS THEMSELVES AND THAT
DOES NOW ALSO I WANT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP THERE AND
BELIEVES THAT THIS COMMITTEE
AND THAT LEGISLATION OTHER
LEGISLATION. THE GOVERNOR'S
WELLS- AND YOU KNOW AND THROUGH
THE BUDGET AND THROUGH THE
LEGISLATION ALSO HAS A BROADER
VARIETY MEASURES TO TRY TO
ADDRESS AGAIN PHARMACEUTICAL
PRICING- FACT THIS YEAR- THE-
GOVERNOR PROPOSED IN HIS
JANUARY BUDGET- THAT- THE STATE
CONSIDER ACTUALLY MANUFACTURING
ITS OWN MEDICATIONS. THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN LOOKING
AT- MY OFFICE AND SO WHEN THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED THAT WE FELT
THAT IT WOULD BE MOST
APPROPRIATE NOT TO JUST DO THAT
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS BUT
ACTUALLY THROUGH THE POLICY
PROCESS SO WE CAN THOROUGHLY
THAT THE- ISSUE AND SO. I
THAT'S WHY I AUTHORED A MOCKERY
SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO SO THAT WE
HAVE A POLICY VETTING OF THIS
ISSUE- THE STATE IN THE CAR.
FOR ARMY. ITS OWN GEN.
MEDICATIONS THOUSAND THAT JAN
BUDGET WE'VE HAD TO OVERCOME.
AND WHILE IT WAS PART OF THE
NAY VICE PACKAGE PARTLY BECAUSE
IT WE DID HOLD IT AS A AS A
POLICY ISSUE. IS STILL ONE I
THINK HAS PARTICULAR RESONANCE
GIVEN. A KOBE. SO WE COME TO
JERRY MEDICATIONS ACTUALLY TWO
ISSUES ONE IS OF COURSE THE
COST ISSUE. THE OTHER ISSUES
ALSO- READY SUPPLY AS WELL SO
WE KNOW THE GENERIC SPACE EVEN
WITHOUT CREE COVE IT. THERE ARE
CERTAIN GENERIC MEDICATIONS AND
WHICH WE COULDN'T GET RELIABLE
SUPPLY. WE ALSO KNOW DOOR OTHER
GENERIC MEDICATIONS WOULD OR
MIGHT BE JUST A SINGLE
MANUFACTURE AND IN FACT PERHAPS
AN INVESTOR WOULD COME AND- BY
THAT SINGLE MANUFACTURE AND
THEN RAISE ITS PRICES AWAY TO.
MAXIMIZE THEIR PROFITS. AND
CAUSING PRICE SPIKES. AND THEN
OF COURSE WE ALSO KNOW THERE'S
OTHER GENERICS IN WHICH- THERE
IS OPPORTUNITY FOR- WHERE
BASICALLY THE PRICE JUST KEEPS
RISING AND THERE'S A NARROW
NUMBER OF MANUFACTURE SO BY.
INCLUDING A- THE STATE IS
ESSENTIALLY A- EITHER A DIRECT
MANUFACTURER OR A CONTRACT TO
MANUFACTURE. THAT WOULD HELP
BUILD STABILIZE PRICE AND
SUPPLY IN ITS ACT ACTUALLY ON
THE PRIVATE SECTOR- THERE'S AN
OLD CALLED CIVIC OF COMPOSED OF
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH PLANS THAT
IS TRYING TO. DO JUST THAT AND
CERTAINLY WE'VE BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED. WITH CIVICA AS
WELL WITHOUT BEING SURE THAT WE
CAN WE HAVE A RELIABLE AND- LOW
COST. GENERIC MEDICATION SINCE.
ARE WE WORKING WITH GOVERNORS.
WELL DEVELOPING THIS BUT LIKE
JUST I WOULD KNOW DURING WE ARE
FOR CHEN. WITH SUPPLIED.
WHETHER IT'S TESTING PP AND
EVEN MEDICATION BY THE WAY SO-
UNFORTUNATELY WE- HAVE NOT SEEN
THE SHORTAGES THAT SOME OF THE
OTHER STATES HAVE SEEN THAT
WORD HOSPITALS WOULD OVERWHELM
THE WORD NOT ONLY FOR THE SHORT
PP. YOUR SHORT OF THE VERY
MEDICATIONS PEOPLE NEED TO GET
TREATED FOR OUR TO BE
INNOVATIVE FOR. A COVETED. AND
SO THIS IS GONNA BE A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP TO CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD. TO LOOK AT BOTH
HOW DO WE ASSURE A STABLE. AND
THE LOW COST COST EFFECTIVE
SUPPLY OF GENERIC MEDICATION.
AND ALSO TO ENSURE THAT WE ALSO
HAVE THE EXPERTISE IN SUPPLY
CHAIN NECESSARY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF DURING. CRISIS. LIKE
OCTOBER NINETEEN. YOU KNOW I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT WELL HIGH
TO CLERK WHEN HIS UNFORTUNATELY
NOT PROVEN TO BE AN EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT FOR COVERED WHEN IT
WAS BEING CONSIDERED- WE
ACTUALLY HAD SHORTAGES NOT JUST
FOR PEOPLE TO COME OF IT BUT
DIRECTLY PEOPLE WHO DO NEED IT
FOR THAT'S EFFECTIVE TREATMENT
FOR LUPUS ARTHRITIS. AND SO-
THIS BILL. CONTINUES TO MOVE
THIS CONVERSATION FORWARD GIVES
THE- MINISTRATION THE
OPPORTUNITYBUT ALSO ENSURES
THAT LEGISLATION INVOLVED IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS POLICY.
SO WE CAN AGAIN GET AHEAD OF
THE PROBLEM INSTEAD OF COSTLY
TRYING TO PLAY CATCH UP- I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I HAVE- TWO WITNESSES
AND SUPPORTS THEIR FLOCKS IN
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
AND YASMIN PALETTE FROM THE-
FROM HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF THIS.
IMPORTANT MEASURE AS A
COMPONENT OF OUR- A COMBINED
EFFORT TO DRESS- PHARMACEUTICAL
COSTS THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
BEFORE WE GO TO OUR WITNESSES
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE OUR OUR
SO. TAKE ROLE WE DO HAVE A
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE QUORUM. SO
ALL HAVE HER DO THAT FIRST. AND
I WOULD JUST RECOGNIZE ALSO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER YEAR
KOREA SECOND BY MISS CARILLO SO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT HERE. WOULD HERE
MAYES. MAYES HERE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW HERE BONTA. BONTA HERE
BURKE. BURKE HERE CARILLO.
CARILLO HERE FLORA LIMóN
MCCARTY NAZARIAN RAMOS RAMOS
HERE RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO SAN
DIEGO HERE WALDRON. YOU HAVE A
QUORUM. SO OF MATTER MARK- I.
IS IT APPROACH THE MATTER
MEMBER MISTER MODERATOR
MODERATOR PLEASE- ALLOW OPEN
THE LINES FOR OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU DON'T
WANT ARE OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF GOOD MORNING THIS IS
SERRA FLAGS O. DE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND WE ARE HERE
BECAUSE EVERY DOLLAR THAT'S
SPENT ON PRESCRIPTION DRUGS IS
A DOLLAR THAT COMES OUT OF A
WORKER'S POCKET. AND
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS ARE THE
FASTEST GROWING COST DRIVER AND
IN HEALTHCARE SPENDING AND IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR COULD GET
18% OF OUR HEALTH CARE SPEND IS
ON DRUGS. CALPERS REPORTS AT
APPROXIMATELY 26% OF THEIR
TOTAL BY. ON TOTAL HEALTHCARE
IS FOR PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. ONE
STRATEGY THAT OUR UNION TRUST
FUNDS IN OUR EMPLOYERS HAVE
USED FOR CONTROLLING DRUG
SPENDING OVER THE YEARS IS
ENSURING THAT MEMBERS USE
GENERIC VERSIONS OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS WHATEVER
MEDICALLY FEASIBLE. OVER THE
RISING COST OF DRUGS BOTTOM
WITH NO CLEAR EXPLANATION DRIVE
UP COSTS FOR EMPLOYERS WORKERS
AND CONSUMERS. GENERIC DRUGS
WHICH ONES WERE ARE LOWER COST
OPTIONS ARE STARTING SKYROCKET.
THE RECENT QUARTERLY A SEVEN
REPORT ON DRUG PRICES SHOW THAT
GENERIC DRUGS HAD A MEDIAN
INCREASE OF THIRTY SEVEN POINT
6% OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD
COMPARED TO A TWENTY FIVE POINT
8% INCREASE FOR ALL DRUGS
OVERALL. SOME EXAMPLES OF THOSE
INCREASES ARE THAT THE PRICE OF
A GENERIC LIQUID VERSION OF
PROZAC. PROZAC WHICH- IS THIRTY
FIRST MOST PRESCRIBED DRUG
NATIONALLY WITH TWO POINT ONE
MILLION PRESCRIPTION. THAT
INCREASED SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SEVEN CENTS. IN PRICE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. EACH EACH JEEP. I TEN
INCREASE IN PRICE MORE THAN
2100% IT IS CLEAR THAT WE HAVE
TO TAKE STEPS TO BE ON
TRANSPARENCY TO FIX THE
PENSIONARY CARE ACT MARKET. ALL
CALIFORNIANS NEED A RELIABLE
AFFORDABLE GENERIC DRUGS
SUPPLIED TO KEEP US HEALTHY. SO
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD IT'S HOME
TO SOME OF THE GREATEST SCIENCE
IN MEDICAL UNIVERSITIES IN THE
COUNTRY SOME OF THE MOST
INNOVATIVE DRUG MANUFACTURERS
IN THE WORLD ARE HEADQUARTERED
HERE ALREADY. WE ALSO HAVE A
HUGE NUMBER OF CONSUMERS
INCLUDING HOSPITALS AND CLINICS
AND THAT WOULD FORCE
MANUFACTURERS TO HAVE TO
COMPETE FOR A MARKET. THIS
STATE IS WELL POSITIONED TO
START OUR OWN GENERICALLY
LABELED TO HELP LOWER PRICES IN
A VERY TARGETED WAY- AND TO
INCREASE THE SUPPLY FOR
EVERYONE AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE HAVE HEARD YOUR SUPPORT SB
EAT BACK TO. THANK YOU. AND OUR
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND NUMBERS YES
MEAN PALETTE ON BEHALF OF
HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION WE ARE HERE
TODAY AND STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FIVE TWO TO CREATE THE
OFFICE OF DRUG CONTRACTING AND
MANUFACTURING. CONSUMERS STILL
STRUGGLE TO ACCESS AND AFFORD
THEIR NEEDED MEDICATIONS ACROSS
ALL SEGMENTS THE PHARMACEUTICAL
BRAND NAME GENERIC SPECIALTY WE
SEE PRICES RISING AROUND 90% OF
ALL PRESCRIPTIONS ARE GENERIC
AND 40% OF ALL GENERIC MEDICINE
ARE MADE BY A SINGLE PENNY
FACTOR ALLOWING THAT MANY
FACTOR TO HIKE PRICES WITHOUT
COMPETITION. ITS CONTROL
ULTIMATELY MEANS BECOMES PAY.
FOR JUST MEDICATIONS THAT
MEASURE. IN SOME CASES SINGLE
MANUFACTURER HAS DRIVEN UP THE
PRICE OF WALKED AT THE- DRUG BY
ASTONISHING ABOUT. I CREATE
THIS OFFICE THEY COULD PROVIDE
RELIEF TO MILLIONS OF CAL.
STRUGGLING WITHOUT COST
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND CREATE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR COMPETITION
IN THE MANUFACTURING. IN
ADDITION TO SAVING COSTS FOR
CONSUMERS THE OFFICE HAS THE
CAPACITY TO STATE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF MONEY. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
BOOK TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- JUST GOING TO THE-
CHAMBERS OR ANYONE IN THE
CHAMBER WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT JUST YOUR NAME AND- A
POSITION ONLY PLEASE. AND ANY
ORGANIZATION MIGHT REPRESENT.
YOUR IS JUST YOUR NAME AND
POSITION PLEASE. ARE YOU
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. WE HEAR
YOU MA'AM. IT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN THE GALLERY. SEE NO ONE
OF GO TO OUR WITNESS ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE WITNESS
ROOM. SPEAKING IN SUPPORT. SEE
NO ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MATTER MODERATOR- THESE
ARE JUST BE FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT JUST YOUR NAME BECAUSE
IT NAME AN ORGAN ORGANIZATIONAL
MYSELF. PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN
YOU'RE READY IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK AND- THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT FIVE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
HELLO FIRST GOT A LINE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWO
FIVE YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CHEN MEMBERS
BENJAMIN TRAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT DOOR TO WHITE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO WAY BOTTOM
ALL REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOTHING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
REPORT THANK YOU. RIGHT
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS AND J. D.
S. ON BEHALF OF S. CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. RIGHT
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BLIND TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN
BRAVO CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ALLEY HOW THAT WOULD ON
WITH VITAMIN GROUP ON BEHALF OF
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
FIACHRA BLOOM QUEST ON BEHALF
OF SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW ELEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT ONE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PROVIDE A LINE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS CARLA
SUPPORTER WITH BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BY TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JENNIFER
PROJECT- CALLING FROM AARP
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
FIVE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OVERLYING
ALIVE IN. GOOD MORNING THREE TO
START WITH KAISER PERMANENTE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER LINE THANK YOU
AT THE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. FOR
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBER IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. I.
SO
JUST JUST JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORG N. WHO YOU REPRESENT IF YOU
DON'T REPRESENT ANYONE JUST
YOUR NAME PLEASE. MY NAME IS
ANDREA HAD STRONG. THANK Y.
AFFILIATION IS A MOTHER OF FOUR
AND I'M MARRIED TO A
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER. AND YOU
SHOULD ALL BE ASHAMED OF
YOURSELF THANK YOU I WAS VERY
IS OPEN THANK YOU TEXAS IS ALL
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION UP THEY'RE- SEE NO
ONE ANYONE IN THE WITNESS ROOM
IN OPPOSITION. IN NO ONE WILL
GO TO THE TELEPHONE LINES
MATTER MODERATOR IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION JUST THEIR
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT FIVE
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO HAVE
ONE IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE GET OUT OF THE NUMBER
I THINK YOU. SLIDE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FIFTEEN
YOUR OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS BRETT MICHELIN WITH THE
ASSOCIATION FOR ACCESSIBLE
MEDICINES THANK IBM REPRESENTS
THE GENERIC AND BIOSIMILAR
MANUFACTURERS AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY WE'RE NOT IN
OPPOSITION BUT- I HOPE YOU'RE
WILLING TO GIVE ME JUST A
COUPLE OF MINUTES- TO- EXPLAIN
A COUPLE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WE HAVE. NOW. WITH THIS BILL I
THINK AS EVEN THE PROPONENT
DISCUSS GENERICS ARE THE BEST
WAY TO REACH THE CALL OF MATTER
WE KNOW 90% OF ALL DRUGS
PRESCRIBED FOR GENERICS BUT YET
THEY'RE ONLY 22% OF THE SPENT
IN CALIFORNIA THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALONE THE STATE SAVE
OVER. TWENTY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS. SOME WAS MADE OF THESE
SIX X. ME WITHOUT WITH THE WITH
ALL DIVERSE WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT- THIS WAS FOR. NAME AND
POSITION ONLY- WE ACTUALLY
DIDN'T HAVE YOU LISTED AS A
WITNESS AND APPRECIATE THAT SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN WRITING. SO I.
YOUR STANDARD EXPRESS MISSION
ASSOCIATION OF ACCESSIBLE
MEDICINES IN OPPOSITION. M.
MODERATOR THERE ANY OTHER
PEOPLE ON THE LINE. I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME RIGHT THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANYONE ON
THE COMMITTEE. HAVE A QUESTION
OR COMMENT. SCENE NINE THE
THERE IS A MOTION FOR THE
MOTION WOULD BE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS THIS
SENATOR HAS ACCEPTED. THE A
AMENDMENTS MOTION BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY THE SECOND BY MISS
KOREA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SENATOR PAT. I JUST HOPE WITH
BEGAN- THANK APPRECIATE- THE
YEAH YOUR LEADERSHIP- DOCTOR
WOULD AND ALSO LEADERSHIP OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE IS AGAIN A VERY
IMPORTANT ANOTHER COMPONENT IN
OUR EFFORT TO. TRY TO BE SURE
WE MAKE. MEDICATIONS MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ID
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE BILL DOESN'T ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB EIGHT
FIVE TO DUE PROCESS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I WOULD I
MAYES. MAYES I ARE YOUR CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NARROW BONTA. BONTA I'D
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO RUBIO AYE
FLORA LEMOND. MCCARTY NAZARIAN
RAMOS MOST I'D RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ ICE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I WALDRON. NINE I WANNA KNOW
BILLY'S OUT BILLS OUT SENATOR
PAN WILL LEAVE THE ROLL UP OR
FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THERE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE IN THE
BUILDING PLEASE COME WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES
AND- AFTER THAT WE'LL CLOSE
ROLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR PAT.
BETTER SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA. LIMóN
MCCARTY. WALDRON WALDRON I'D-
THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS LIMON. PARTY
NEWMAN AYE MCCARTY NAZARIAN.
OKAY OKAY THANK YOU SO THE VOTE
IS. ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ONE
ELEVEN ONE EXCUSE ME ELEVEN
ONE- AND SECRETARY WE WILL NOW
GO AHEAD AND CLOSE THE HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE.